Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. At the end of France, there is a plain filled with woods and fruit trees. In this narrow place, there lived a great number of very tough, strong people, the name of whom was Normans. Such were their numbers, that in time as the population grew, the fields and orchards of Normandy proved insufficient to keep them all fed. Therefore, the Normans scattered here and there throughout all the various parts of the world, making their way
感谢收听《The Rest is History》。想要获取每周独家节目、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验以及加入我们备受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。在法国的尽头，有一片平原，长满了树木和果树。在这个狭窄的地方，生活着大量非常顽强、强壮的人，他们的名字叫诺曼人。他们的人数如此之多，以至于随着时间的推移，人口增长，诺曼底的田野和果园证明已不足以维持他们所有人的温饱。因此，诺曼人四处分散到世界各地，踏上了
into numerous regions and countries, abandoning what little they had in order to obtain very much more. These people departed their homes, but they did not follow the custom of most people who go through the world, entering into the service of others. Rather, like warriors of old, their aim was to make everybody subject to them and under their lordship. And so they took up arms and broke the bond of peace and whether as a mass of infantrymen or on horseback they proved themselves great in deeds. So that was the terrifying opening to the history of the Normans written Tom in the mid 11th century by a monk called Amartas.
进入许多地区和国家的道路，放弃了他们仅有的一点东西，以换取更多的财富。这些人离开了家乡，但他们并没有遵循大多数人的习俗，即云游四海并为他人效劳。相反，就像古代的勇士一样，他们的目标是让所有人臣服于他们并受其统治。因此，他们拿起武器，打破了和平的契约，无论是作为步兵还是骑兵，他们在行动中都证明了自己是伟大的。因此，正如11世纪中期一位名叫阿玛塔斯的僧侣所写的那样，那是对诺曼人历史的骇人听闻的开端。
And as you have pointed out in your notes, this is very reminiscent of the way that, you know, when the Greeks wrote about the intrusion on the world scene of the Romans or the Chinese about the coming of the Mongols, they would say, oh my God, there's this extraordinary new people who are absolutely formidable, very frightening, very brutal. They kill everybody. They, you know, where they come from. Yeah. Where they come from.
正如你在笔记中所指出的，这非常让人联想到这样的方式，你知道的，当希腊人书写罗马人对世界舞台的入侵时，或者中国人在书写蒙古人的到来时，他们会说，天哪，出现了一群非同寻常的新人，他们绝对是令人敬畏的、非常可怕的、非常残酷的。他们杀死所有人。他们，你知道的，他们是从哪里来的。是的。他们是从哪里来的。
And the Normans are greeted by writers beyond Normandy's borders with the same kind of awe and terror on they. Yeah. Kind of dread for reasons that Amartya spells out because he says that the Normans are physically hardy, very tough, very strong. So Amartya writes in Latin, but the version we have is translated into French. And he specifies that the Normans have a lust for seignory, so lordship. Yeah. And that they have a particular aptitude for chevalerie, so fighting on horseback, what
诺曼底边境以外的作家们对诺曼人的到来抱有一种敬畏和恐惧，不是吗？是的。出于阿玛塔斯所阐述的原因，有一种恐惧感，因为他说诺曼人身体健壮、非常顽强、非常强大。所以阿玛塔斯是用拉丁文写作的，但我们拥有的版本是被翻译成法文的。他明确指出，诺曼人对封地（即统治权）有着强烈的渴望。是的。他们对骑士精神（即骑马作战）有着特殊的才能，这
will in due course come to be the attribute of a knight chivalry. But basically they're going around on horses, kind of nicking other people's land and property. And also, of course, he's very impressed by their wanderlust, this sense that they're spilling out across the world and that their goal is a kind of greatness. That they're not prepared to serve other people. And Amartas is speaking from experience. prepared to serve other people. And Amartas is speaking from experience. So he is a monk in Monte Cassino, the great abbey in central Italy, which we last heard of in the podcast because Wojtek.
将在日后成为骑士的特征。但基本上他们骑着马到处跑，抢夺别人的土地和财产。当然，他也对他们的漫游癖印象深刻，这种他们向世界各地扩散、他们的目标是一种伟大的感觉。他们不准备为其他人服务。阿玛塔斯的话是基于经验的。准备为其他人服务。阿玛塔斯的话是基于经验的。因此，他是意大利中部伟大修道院——卡西诺山的一名僧侣，我们在上一期播客中听到这个名字是因为沃伊泰克。
The bear, the Polish bear. Yes, the Polish bear was serving with the Polish army there in the Second World War. But it's a very venerable abbey reaching back to the beginnings of Christianity in Italy. And the fact that he is observing this from Italy is a reminder to us in England, we tend to think of the Norman conquest as the Normans are going one way. He has seen a great stream of Norman free-booters, adventurers, rogues, mercenaries, whatever, heading south into Italy and beyond. And actually, for me, one of the great fascinating stories of Normans is how they expand southwards
那只熊，波兰熊。是的，波兰熊在第二次世界大战期间在那里随波兰军队服役。但这是一座非常古老的修道院，可以追溯到基督教在意大利的起源。他在意大利观察到这一点，这提醒了我们这些在英国的人，我们倾向于认为诺曼征服是诺曼人单向的行动。他看到了大量诺曼自由雇佣兵、冒险家、流氓、雇佣兵等，向南涌入意大利及更远地区。实际上，对我来说，诺曼人最迷人的故事之一就是他们如何向南扩张
and become a Mediterranean power. Well, because Southern Italy in particular, I mean, if you're going out and you're looking for opportunities to set up your lordship, then you want a place where there are gonna be rich pickings and Southern Italy is perfect for the Norman's purpose because this is a place where all kinds of different empires
并成为地中海强权。好吧，因为特别是意大利南部，我的意思是，如果你出海寻找建立统治的机会，那么你会想要一个有很多丰厚战利品的地方，而意大利南部非常符合诺曼人的目的，因为这是一个各种不同帝国
are rubbing up against each other. So there's Latin Christendom, but there is also the Byzantine Empire. So the Byzantines have territory there and there's Muslim powers in Sicily and kind of constant ambitions to push up northwards through Italy. So this is perfect for a bunch of kind of hardy horse riding mercenaries looking essentially to be paid and then to use that money to turn on the people who are paying them. The first Normans who get hired in southern Italy are actually pilgrims returning from Jerusalem. They land on the heel of Italy in 1018 from Jerusalem and they get employed by rebels against Byzantine rule, so Italian speaking rebels. And then four years later, they've switched sides
相互碰撞的地方。因此，这里有拉丁基督教世界，但也有拜占庭帝国。因此拜占庭人在那里拥有领土，西西里岛也有穆斯林势力，并且有着不断向北推进穿过意大利的野心。所以这对于一群寻找基本报酬、然后利用这笔钱来对付付钱给他们的那些人的强悍骑马雇佣兵来说是完美的。第一批在意大利南部受雇的诺曼人实际上是从耶路撒冷返回的朝圣者。他们在1018年从耶路撒冷在意大利的脚跟登陆，他们被反抗拜占庭统治的叛军（即说意大利语的叛军）所雇用。然后四年后，他们转换了阵营
and they're in the service of the Byzantine Empire. And then within a decade, these kind of Norman mercenaries, strong men are carving out their own fiefdoms and a martyr from his vantage point in Monte Cassino about halfway up Italy. He's full of admiration actually for their kind of prowess, for their energy, for their chutzpah really, just taking their opportunities. But there are other monks at Monte Cassino who are slightly more jaundice. So the abbot of Monte Cassino is a guy called Desiderius and he will actually go on to become Pope and he views these Norman adventurers kind of as a
并且效力于拜占庭帝国。然后在十年之内，这些诺曼雇佣兵和强人开辟了他们自己的封地，而位于意大利中部大约一半路程的卡西诺山的阿玛塔斯从他的有利位置出发。实际上，他对他们的英勇、他们的活力、他们的厚颜无耻充满了钦佩，他们只是抓住了机会。但卡西诺山还有其他一些僧侣的态度则稍微有些悲观。卡西诺山的院长是一个叫德西德里乌斯的人，他实际上后来成为了教皇，他将这些诺曼冒险家视为
wolf pack that they've been driven southwards by hunger and they are hungry for blood. So he wrote the Normans are avid for rapine and possess an insatiable appetite for seizing what belongs to others. It's not entirely wrong. Not entirely wrong and a perspective that others as well as the Italians will come to get. Yeah.
狼群，他们被饥饿驱赶向南，他们对鲜血充满渴望。因此他写道：“诺曼人热衷于掠夺，对夺取他人财产有着无饱餍的渴望。”这并不完全错。并非完全错，这也是除了意大利人之外，其他人也会形成的看法。是的。
And I suppose a question that the Italians might have pondered was why didn't impercunious Normans, you know, if they, if they're looking for lordships, why aren't they doing it near a home? Why are they coming to Italy to do it? Okay. Well, let me just pause you there. So last time we heard about how Normandy was established. So that's under a guy called Rollo or Rolf. So we're talking about Northmen Vikings effectively, who have carved out and semi being granted this territory in Northern France by Charles the Simple. And that was in the early 10th century. So Rollo died probably about 930.
我想意大利人可能会琢磨的一个问题是，为什么身无分文的诺曼人，你知道的，如果他们在寻找领地，为什么他们不在离家近的地方做这件事？为什么他们要来意大利做这件事？好吧，让我在这里暂停一下。所以上一次我们听说了诺曼底是如何建立的。那是 在一个叫罗洛或罗尔夫的人的领导下。所以我们实际上是在谈论诺曼维京人，他们开辟了这块领土，并在某种程度上由简单王查理授予他们在法国北部的这块领土。那是在10世纪初。所以罗洛大概在930年左右去世。
But now we've moved on a bit in time. So the last person that we met who was the kind of the leader of the Normans was a guy called Richard the second, Richard the good. So he's the brother in law of two other characters that we met last time, Ethel ready and ready and Knute. And he had kept Normandy pretty settled, stable, secure. And he's of course the brother as well of Emma of Normandy, who's got herself mixed up in all kinds of exciting dynastic shenanigans over in England, which it would take another hour to explain. So Richard II in Normandy, things actually have been very ordered and secure under him, right?
但现在我们在时间上向前推进了一点。所以我们见到的最后一个作为诺曼人领袖的人物是一个叫理查二世的人，即好人理查。所以他是我们上次见到的另外两个角色——埃塞尔雷德和克努特的小舅子。他使诺曼底保持了相当安定、稳定和安全。当然，他也是诺曼底的埃玛的兄弟，埃玛自己卷入了英国各种令人兴奋的王朝阴谋中，这需要再花一个小时才能解释清楚。所以在诺曼底的理查二世统治下，事情实际上非常有序，而且在他的统治下很安全，对吧？
Yeah. So and the measure of this is that initially he'd begun life as the Count of Rouen, but he's kind of promoted himself to become the Duke of Normandy. And essentially, by the end of his life, everyone else, including the King of France has basically said, yeah, okay, you know, you can rank as a Duke or in Latin a Dux. So this is the route of Duce that, you know, the title that Mussolini takes up. It's to be essentially a kind of military strongman as much as anything else. And in the context of France, there are five dukes, as well as the Duke of Normandy. So the Duke of Burgundy, the Duke of Aquitaine of Gascony,
是的。衡量这一点的标准是，他最初以鲁昂伯爵的身份开始其生涯，但他将自己提升为诺曼底公爵。基本上，到他生命结束时，包括法兰克国王在内的其他所有人基本上都说，是的，好吧，你可以被称为公爵（拉丁语中为 Dux）。所以这就是“领袖”（Duce，墨索里尼采用的头衔）这个词的根源。这基本上就是成为一个军事强人以及其他任何东西。在法国的背景下，除了诺曼底公爵之外，还有五位公爵。即勃艮第公爵、阿基坦公爵、加斯科涅公爵，
and directly on Normandy's Western Frank, the Duke of Brittany. And to be a Duke in 11th century France is not the equivalent of being, say, an Earl in England. Because we talked in the first episode about how over the course of the 10th and into the 11th century, the kings of England have massively consolidated and centralized their power over this kind of very precociously united kingdom. But in France, the opposite process has been happening. Royal power has kind of ebbed and bled away. And by this point, so early 11th century, in France, the king exercises direct rule only over a tiny patchwork of territories centered on Paris and Orleans. So to rule as the Duke of Normandy is to enjoy an autonomy, a kind of degree of independence that is beyond the wildest dreams of, you know, the Earl of East Anglia or the Earl
以及直接位于诺曼底西翼的布列塔尼公爵。在11世纪的法国成为一名公爵并不等于成为英国的伯爵。因为我们在第一集里讨论过，在10世纪到11世纪的过程中，英国国王如何在这样一个过早统一的王国中极大地巩固和集权他们的权力。但在法国，相反的过程一直在发生。王权已经消退和流失。到了这个时候，也就是11世纪初，在法国，国王直接统治的仅仅是以巴黎和奥尔良为中心的一小块零散领土。因此，作为诺曼底公爵统治意味着享有自治权，这种独立程度超出了东盎格利亚伯爵或
of Mercia. And to give people a sense, I mean, it's far more than let's say, I don't know, being the governor of a US state or something, because you're also an international player, aren't you? You can almost run your own foreign policy. Is that fair? Well, so we talked at the end of the last episode about how Richard's son Robert, who rules as Duke for almost a decade in 1035, he goes off on pilgrimage to Jerusalem. And we were expressing surprise at this because Normandy potentially would be in an unstable situation where he'd die. But one of the reasons he's going is undoubtedly because he's very pious. He wants to go to Jerusalem for those reasons. But also, he wants to cut a dash. He wants to display his wealth, his power, his authority on the grandest of international stages, which if you're a Christian is Constantinople. Yeah. Still the greatest city in the Christian world.
麦西亚伯爵的最疯狂梦想。为了给人们一个概念，我的意思是，这远不止是，比方说，成为一个美国州的州长之类的人，因为你也是一个国际玩家，对吧？你几乎可以运行你自己的外交政策。这样说公平吗？好吧，所以在上一集的结尾，我们讨论了理查的儿子罗伯特，他在1035年作为公爵统治了近十年，他去耶路撒冷朝圣。我们对此表示惊讶，因为如果他死了，诺曼底可能会处于不稳定状态。但他去的其中一个原因无疑是因为他非常虔诚。出于这些原因，他想去耶路撒冷。但同时，他也想出彩。他想在最宏大的国际舞台上展示他的财富、他的力量和他的权威，如果你是一个基督徒，这个舞台就是君士坦丁堡。是的。它依然是基督教世界中最伟大的城市。
And so he travels from Normandy to Constantinople and he cuts an absolutely amazing dash. You know, the Byzantines are really dazzled. And this is despite the fact that they've had some dealings with the Normans in the south of Italy. So they trust them, but they are impressed. And you know, there are these reports that even his mules are shot with gold. And it said that his campfires are fueled with the shells of pistachio nuts. And this is regarded even by the Byzantines as the height of the height of high living.
因此，他从诺曼底旅行到君士坦丁堡，他的表现极其惊艳。你知道的，拜占庭人真的被迷住了。尽管他们与意大利南部的诺曼人有过一些交往，情况确实如此。所以他们信任他们，但他们留下了深刻的印象。你知道的，有报道称，甚至他的骡子都用金子钉蹄。据说他的营火是用开心果壳作为燃料的。即使对拜占庭人来说，这也算得上是奢华生活的高峰。
And so they call him the magnificent. Okay, which from a Byzantine paying, you know, paying tribute to a barbarian from the wild and frozen north is not bad. I mean, that is kind of measure of his standing. And yet Normandy itself is, you know, not remotely as rich and powerful as the Eastern Roman Empire, the Byzantine Empire, because not least because Normandy is embattled, right? It's surrounded by predators and rivals. Yes, because the King of France doesn't exercise a kind of controlling authority, it means that all these various dukes and counts, if they're to rule their territory and perhaps expand them, they have to be very militarily proficient and they can't afford a single
因此他们称他为“宏伟者”。好吧，对于一个向来自蛮荒冰冷北方的野蛮人致敬的拜占庭人来说，这还算不错。我的意思是，这算是对他地位的一种衡量。然而诺曼底本身，你知道的，远不如东罗马帝国、拜占庭帝国那么富有和强大，原因之一就是诺曼底四面楚歌，对吧？它被掠夺者和竞争对手包围着。是的，因为法兰克国王没有行使一种控制性的权力，这意味着所有这些大大小小的公爵和伯爵，如果他们要统治他们的领土并可能将其扩展，他们必须在军事上非常熟练，并且他们承受不起哪怕一次
slip because as you say, there are predators lurking everywhere. So in the case of the Norman Dukes, these predators would include most obviously, I suppose the King of France himself, because Paris is upriver from Rouen and that's the great center of French royal power. And the King of France is therefore a kind of brooding, slightly ambivalent presence. The dukes have always been kind of essentially loyal to the King of France and the King of France has shown favour to them. But the risk is that if they seem too powerful, then the King may turn against them. So that's an obvious risk.
失误，因为正如你所说，到处都潜伏着掠夺者。所以在诺曼公爵的例子中，这些掠夺者最明显的应该包括法兰克国王本人，因为巴黎在鲁昂的上游，那是法兰克王权伟大的中心。因此法兰克国王是一种挥之不去的、略带矛盾的存在。公爵们一直基本上忠于法兰克国王，法兰克国王也对他们表现出青睐。但风险在于，如果他们看起来太强大，那么国王可能会反对他们。所以这是一个明显的风险。
Okay. And then on the western flank of Normandy, we've already mentioned the dukes of Brittany and the Bretons are seen rather like the Romans used to see the ancient Britons as just complete barbarians. So a Norman writer describes them as an uncivilized and quick tempered people lacking any manners. And rather as the Romans did at talking about the Britons goes on about how they like to drink milk Well, you know my views on that my sister-in-law went out with a man called Paddy and he only drank milk We went with them to Lisbon and he only drank milk and they don't the Portuguese aren't really into drinking milk
好的。然后在诺曼底的西翼，我们已经提到了布列塔尼公爵，布列塔尼人被看待的方式有点像罗马人过去看待古代不列颠人那样，纯粹是野蛮人。因此，一位诺曼作家将他们描述为不文明、脾气暴躁、缺乏任何礼貌的人。就像罗马人在谈论不列颠人时所做的那样，他接着谈到他们喜欢喝牛奶。好吧，你知道我对这件事的看法，我小舅子和一个叫帕迪的男人交往，而他只喝牛奶。我们和他们一起去里斯本，而他只喝牛奶，而葡萄牙人其实并不喜欢喝牛奶。
So it was a total washout and I've always been bitter about it since then I mean I didn't drink milk the norm is do in the long run go and they go and Besiege and take Lisbon, don't they, in the Second Crusade? So this is what happens if you just, if you, yeah, if you get involved with this milk drinking business all kinds of horrors will follow. Yeah. So the Bretons are a constant challenge, but the most dangerous adversaries of the Norman dukes are the Counts of Anjou who lie to the south and Anjou is centered on the
所以那是一次彻头彻尾的失败，从那以后我一直对此耿耿于怀。我的意思是，我没有喝牛奶。从长远来看，诺曼人确实去了，他们在第二次世界大战期间去围攻并占领了里斯本，不是吗？这就是如果你卷入这种喝牛奶的生意，各种恐怖的事情接踵而至的结果。是的。因此，布列塔尼人是一个持续的挑战，但诺曼公爵最危险的对手是位于南方的安茹伯爵，安茹是以
Loire and these are counts not Dukes. So you might think, well, they're slightly second division. And there's an additional reason why it might seem slightly puzzling that the counts of Anjou are such a menace because there is actually a buffer zone between Normandy and Anjou, which is the county of Maine. So Le Mans, as in the motor racing. Yeah. I mean, obviously not in the 11th century, but that's all lying in the future. I'm glad you clarified that.
卢瓦尔河为中心的，这些是伯爵而不是公爵。所以你可能会认为，好吧，他们有点属于二级联赛。还有一个额外的原因，为什么安茹伯爵是一个如此巨大的威胁可能会显得有点令人困惑，因为在诺曼底和安茹之间实际上有一个缓冲区，那就是曼恩伯爵领地。就像赛车中的勒芒那样。是的。我的意思是，显然不是在11世纪，但那都是未来的事了。我很高兴你澄清了这一点。
Yeah, I just make sure that's clear. So this is a buffer zone, but it is clear that the counts of Anjou are in a way the most Norman rival that the Normans have. You could look at the countss of Anjou and say, yeah, they have something of the predatory quality of the Dukes of Normandy, because like the Dukes of Normandy, they are relative upstarts, they're very ambitious, they're exceedingly brutal, and they're very cunning, very politically proficient. And the Count of Anjou, as Robert rides off on his pilgrimage going off to Jerusalem, is gnarled, terrifying, completely brutal warlord called Falknera.
是的，我只是确保这一点很清楚。所以这是一个缓冲区，但很明显，安茹伯爵在某种程度上是诺曼人最核心的竞争对手。你可以看看安茹伯爵，然后说，是的，他们具有诺曼底公爵那种掠夺性的特质，因为就像诺曼底公爵一样，他们是相对的暴发户，他们非常有野心，极其残忍，而且非常狡猾，政治上非常精明。当罗伯特骑着马去朝圣去耶路撒冷时，安茹伯爵是一个饱经风霜、极其恐怖、完全残酷的军阀，名叫“黑富尔克”。
His nickname is the Black. Falk the Black, that's a great name. Falknera the Black. And he has been in power for essentially half a century. So he succeeded his father back in 987 and over the course of the 50 years that he's been count of Angers, I mean, he again and again displays his capacity for violence and vengeance and perhaps the most notorious episode from his life. So in the year 1000 itself, the great citadel in Angers, which is his, essentially his capital, gets
他的绰号是“黑色”。黑富尔克，这是一个伟大的名字。黑色富尔克。他掌权基本上已有半个世纪。所以他早在987年就继承了他父亲的衣钵，在他担任昂热伯爵的50年里，我的意思是，他一次又一次地展示了他对暴力和复仇的能力，他生命中最臭名昭著的插曲也许是。所以在公元1000年本身，昂热的伟大城堡，也就是他的，基本上是他的首都，被
seized and held against him. And what is shocking about this absolute stab in the back is that the person who has led the rebellion against him is Fulknera's own wife. And the reason that she's done this is that Fulknera has realized that she's been having an affair with someone else. So I mean, cook holding someone like Fulknera is very, very foolish. So he is not happy about this. He sweeps into Angers, he storms the citadel, absolute carnage, most of Angers laid to waste, and his wife is captured and burnt at the stake. And that is a very public statement that you know do
攻占并被用于对抗他。而这次绝对背叛最令人震惊的是，领导反抗他的人正是富尔克自己的妻子。她这样做的原因是富尔克意识到她一直在和别人有染。所以我的意思是，给像富尔克这样的人戴绿帽子是非常非常愚蠢的。所以他对这件事很不高兴。他席卷昂热，突袭了城堡，绝对是一场大屠杀，昂热的大部分地方都被摧毁了，他的妻子被捕并在火刑柱上烧死。这是一个非常公开的声明，你知道的，不要
not cross him. But also what Fulk represents and people like him represent is something bigger than just the sort of the dynastic soap opera of 10th century politics. He's not a blowhard, he's not just a kind of wild barbarian. There is a, is it fair to call it a revolution, there is a massive transition in European military life underway at this point, of which the Normans will be the great beneficiaries and the embodiment. And that transition comes about, of course, because, and here's what I think a crucial difference between France and England. France is so divided and fragmented,
惹恼他。但同时，富尔克所代表的以及像他这样的人所代表的东西，不仅仅是10世纪政治王朝肥皂剧那么简单。他不是一个夸夸其谈的人，他不仅仅是一个狂野的野蛮人。存在着一场，称之为革命是否公平，欧洲军事生活正在进行一场巨大的转型，诺曼人将成为这场转型的巨大受益者和体现者。当然，这种转型的发生是因为，这里我认为是法国和英国之间的一个关键区别。法国是如此分裂和破碎，
it's competitive, it's militarily competitive, and that breeds technological change. Absolutely. So the 11th century in France particularly is a period of such transformation that I think it is not an exaggeration to call it a revolution. Europe's first great revolution and it affects almost every aspect. So we will see it's religious, it's social, it's cultural, but it is also military. So just focusing specifically on the military revolution that is happening in France at this time, it is absolutely, as you say, a consequence of the breakdown of royal authority in France. And back in the time of Charlemagne, it's a prerogative of the king to set up fortifications, to build battlements. That's essentially his job.
它是竞争激烈的，在军事上是竞争激烈的，这孕育了技术变革。绝对是的。因此，法国的11世纪特别是一个充满这种变革的时期，我认为称其为一场革命并不过分。欧洲的第一场伟大革命，它影响了几乎每一个方面。所以我们会看到它是宗教的、社会的、文化的，但它也是军事的。因此，仅仅专门聚焦于当时在法国发生的军事革命，正如你所说，它绝对是法国王权崩溃的结果。早在查理曼大帝时代，建立防御工事、建造城垛是国王的特权。这基本上是他的工作。
But by the time the Carolingian dynasty, the dynasty of Charlemagne has gone extinct in France and has been replaced by the Capetian dynasty, the Capetians are struggling to hold onto their own territory. And so their fortifications, rather than expressing their ability to control the whole of France, are an index of the fact that they're losing
但到了加洛林王朝（查理曼大帝的王朝）在法国绝嗣并被卡佩王朝取代时，卡佩王朝正在艰难地维持他们自己的领土。因此，他们的防御工事与其说是他们控制整个法国能力的体现，不如说是他们正在失去
control. And because they've lost control, it means that in lands beyond their own heartlands, other figures, the dukes, the counts, whoever, they are starting now to build fortifications because the king is not in a position to stop them. And if you think of France as kind of rotting wood, these fortifications are like fungi, like mushrooms sprouting up out of the wood. And these are strange, unsettling structures. No one's ever seen anything quite like them before. And these are structures that in French will come to be called chateau and in English castles. And the greatest castle builder of his generation is Faulknerer. Castles are the basis of his power and his expansionism. And it reflects a very cold-eyed insight, which is that you can use castles not just for defense, but for attack.
控制的一个指标。因为他们失去了控制，这意味着在他们自己的核心领地之外的土地上，其他人物——公爵、伯爵或任何人——现在开始建造防御工事，因为国王没有能力阻止他们。如果你把法国想象成腐烂的木头，这些防御工事就像从木头上长出来的真菌、蘑菇一样。这些是奇怪的、令人不安的结构。以前从来没有人见过类似的东西。这些是在法语中被称为“chateau”（城堡），在英语中被称为“castles”的结构。而他那一代最伟大的城堡建造者就是黑富尔克。城堡是他权力和扩张主义的基础。这反映了一种极其冷静的洞察力，那就是你可以把城堡不仅用于防御，还可以用于进攻。
Right. These are tools of dominance and oppression. They're tools, they're symbols of surveillance and control, but they're also, you know, they're impregnable. You put them on a hill or on a rocky outcrop or whatever it might be and there's no way that the pits people in the surrounding countryside can store or very difficult for them to storm it. You control that territory now once you put down your castle. Yeah. So, I mean, essentially you can plant it in enemy territory and you put it on a crag or whatever, a cliff. And if you can't find a crag or a cliff, then you can, you know, you can build a great mound of earth that comes to be called a motte. But essentially you're seizing territory that previously had had no value at all, but now
对。这些是统治和压迫的工具。它们是工具，是监视和控制的符号，但它们也是，你知道的，坚不可摧的。你把它们放在山上、岩石露头上或其他任何地方，周边乡村的人根本无法攻克，或者他们很难攻克。一旦你建立起你的城堡，你现在就控制了那片领土。是的。所以，我的意思是，基本上你可以把它安插在敌人的领土上，你把它放在悬崖峭壁或其他什么地方。如果你找不到悬崖或峭壁，那么你可以，你知道的，你可以建造一座被称为“motte”（土墩）的大型土丘。但基本上你是在夺取以前没有任何价值的领土，但现在
it enables you to be proactive because you can build a very rough castle out of wood. It can be incredibly rudimentary. We're not talking great towers of stone or anything like that. But because people are not used to the idea of fortifications suddenly sprouting up, it has an outsized effect on the ability of those who control these structures to then impose themselves and intimidate people who are all around them. And once you've done that, once you've used these kind of makeshift structures, these castles to grab an area of territory, and if you keep it, then of course, in time,
它使你能够采取主动，因为你可以用木头建造一座非常简陋的城堡。它可以是极其粗糙的。我们谈论的不是巨大的石头塔楼或其他类似的东西。但因为人们不习惯突然冒出防御工事的想法，它对那些控制这些结构的人随后施加自己并恐吓周围所有人的能力产生了巨大的影响。一旦你这样做了，一旦你利用这些权宜之计的结构，这些城堡来夺取一块领土，如果你守住了它，那么当然，随着时间的推移，
you can, I don't know, rebuild them in stone or whatever. And this is what Falknera has been doing. And so the result is that, you know, he's been in power for decades and decades and decades. By the 1030s, Anjou has come to be shielded all along its frontiers by kind of great donjons built on their crags, built on their moths, and they're essentially impregnable.
你可以，我不知道，用石头重建它们之类的事情。这就是黑富尔克一直在做的事情。因此结果是，你知道的，他已经掌权了几十年又几十年。到1030年代，安茹的整个边境都受到了建在悬崖上、建在土墩上的巨大城堡（donjons）的保护，它们基本上是坚不可摧的。
And it means therefore that Anjou itself is impregnable. But because of course, France is such a competitive arena, Anjou's neighbors then have to follow suit, don't they? So that by this point, or certainly by the time Robert goes off on his jaunt to the Holy Land, Normandy too has lots of castles, so you have to because it's basically a harm's race. Yeah. But I guess the question then is, is there a kind of human dimension to this? And this is a really interesting story. Of course, because it's a military revolution that is also a social revolution. So it is creating an entire new class of people. Because these
这也意味着安茹本身是坚不可摧的。但当然，因为法国是一个如此竞争激烈的竞技场，安茹的邻居们随后也不得不效仿，不是吗？因此到这个时候，或者当然在罗伯特去圣地游玩时，诺曼底也有了大量的城堡，所以你必须这样做，因为这基本上是一场军备竞赛。是的。但我想问题是，这其中是否有一种人性的维度？这是一个非常有趣的故事。当然，因为这是一场军事革命，同时也是一场社会革命。所以它正在创造一个全新的人阶层。因为这些
castles obviously to be effective, they have to be held by warriors who are very well armed, probably who have armor, you know, chainmail, and they have to be mobile. Because if you're using the castle as a base, then you need to be able to sweep across the surrounding territory and intimidate anyone there, which effectively means that you need horses. And how are you going to pay for this? How are you going to pay for the horses, the armor, the swords and whatever, the lances? The answer obviously is you're going to do it mafia style by extorting cash out of those who don't have horses and armor, which effectively means the local peasantry.
城堡为了有效，显然必须由装备精良的武士来把守，他们可能拥有盔甲，你知道的，链甲，而且他们必须是机动的。因为如果你把城堡作为基地，那么你需要能够横扫周围的领土并恐吓那里的任何人，这实际上意味着你需要马匹。你将如何为此付钱？你将如何支付马匹、盔甲、剑、长矛之类的费用？答案很明显，你将以黑手党的方式，通过向没有马匹和盔甲的人勒索现金来做到这一点，这实际上意味着当地的农民。
And up until the 11th century in France, peasantry essentially had been scattered. But now they get kind of herded like sheep or cattle into pens. And these pens are what come to be called villages. So the emergence of the castle also sees the emergence of the village. And it's the, I suppose the kind of the classic image that people would have of the middle ages, of a great castle and peasants and villages clustered around the castle. This is where that kind of image is originating.
直到11世纪的法国，农民基本上都是分散的。但现在他们有点像羊或牛一样被赶进畜栏。而这些畜栏就是后来被称为村庄的地方。因此，城堡的出现也伴随着村庄的出现。这是我猜人们对中世纪的经典印象，即一座巨大的城堡，以及聚集在城堡周围的农民和村庄。这种形象就是从这里起源的。
And to contemporaries who are living through this, it's a completely shocking and settling, terrifying experience because suddenly you're getting these gangs of male clad thugs galloping through across territory where previously there hadn't been such figures to menace and intimidate. And clerics and monks, they don't know what to call them. But gradually the word that they start to use to describe these figures, these, these kinds of heavies in there on their horses, because they're horses, they come to be called chevalier. So people who
对于经历这一切的同代人来说，这是一种完全令人震惊、不安和可怕的经历，因为突然之间，你看到这些身穿铠甲的暴徒帮派在以前没有这种人物出没、无法进行威胁和恐吓的领土上驰骋。神职人员和僧侣不知道该怎么称呼他们。但渐渐地，他们开始用来描述这些人物的词——这些骑在马上的重装骑兵，因为他们骑着马——被称为“chevalier”：那些
ride a chevalier horse and in English, these figures will come to be called knickknicks, knights. So we've got the castles, we've got the village, we've got the night. It's all kicking off. But the paradox though, right. Is that if you have your full narrow or whoever who controls all this stuff, this makes him, you know, much more powerful in and, and, and, and the potential therefore for a very strong and domineering state indeed, on the other hand, if they're not controlled, they could easily be tools for complete fragmentation. You know, you could have independent castles and independent groups
骑着“chevalier”（马）的人，而在英语中，这些人物后来被称为“knights”（骑士）。所以我们有了城堡，有了村庄，有了骑士。一切都在如火如荼地进行。但矛盾的是，对吧？如果你有你的黑富尔克或任何控制这一切的人，这使他，你知道的，在各方面都变得更加强大，因此确实存在建立一个非常强大且专制国家的潜力；另一方面，如果他们不受控制，他们很容易成为彻底分裂的工具。你知道的，你可能会有独立的城堡和独立的骑士群体
of knights and all this kind of thing. So if you have a weak king or a weak count or duke or whatever, then the potential for complete anarchy is sure an armed and violent anarchy is surely greater than ever before. Yeah, absolutely. And there is an illustration of this, of course, in southern Italy, because this is exactly the process that's been happening. Because there isn't a centralized power there, because you have all these rival empires who
以及所有这类事情。因此，如果你有一个软弱的国王或一个软弱的伯爵或公爵之类的人，那么完全无政府状态的潜力——武装且暴力的无政府状态——无疑比以往任何时候都要大。是的，绝对是这样。当然，意大利南部就有一个这样的例子，因为这正是正在发生的过程。因为那里没有集权的权力，因为你有所有这些相互竞争的帝国
are competing for these mercenaries, these Norman knights on their horses with their mail and their armor and their spears, there is a massive opportunity for these mercenaries then to build castles there. That's what they're doing. That is how they seize their fiefdoms. You know, you can grab a crag or whatever as Fulcnero had been doing in Anjou and do it in southern Italy. And you've got, you know, perfect base for practicing kind of terrorism essentially, kind of the Mafia law. And all you need really is a horse and armor and arms.
他们在争夺这些雇佣兵，这些骑着马、穿着链甲和盔甲、拿着长矛的诺曼骑士，这些雇佣兵在那里建立城堡有着巨大的机会。这就是他们正在做的。这就是他们夺取封地的方式。你知道的，你可以像黑富尔克在安茹做的那样，在意大利南部抢占一个悬崖或类似的东西。而且你拥有，你知道的，进行某种恐怖主义、某种黑手党法律的完美基地。你真正需要的只是一匹马、盔甲和武器。
And the question is, of course, if that can happen in southern Italy, then why not in Normandy itself? If there is not a strong duke, then there will be no one to stop people back in the Norman homeland from doing exactly what they're doing in southern Italy. All of which means that for Robert the Magnificent, for all his magnificence, going off on his pilgrimage is kind of risky and dare I say irresponsible. I mean, he is the authority figure.
当然，问题是，如果这能在意大利南部发生，为什么不在诺曼底本身发生呢？如果没有一个强有力的公爵，那么将没有人能够阻止诺曼故乡的人们做他们在意大利南部正在做的事情。所有这一切都意味着，对于伟大的罗伯特来说，尽管他很伟大，但去朝圣有点冒险，我敢说是不负责任的。我的意思是，他是权威人物。
If he leaves, isn't there a danger that all the different mercenary bands, as it were, will set up their own private fiefdoms? Yeah, it's at the height of irresponsibility for reasons that we touched on at the end of the last episode, but just to recap, the succession in Normandy is rocky. Robert does have a son, this boy, seven years old, called William, and in fact, before he left on pilgrimage, he had officially nominated this boy as his heir and he had won the sanction for doing this of the King of France.
如果他离开，难道不存在所有的雇佣兵团都会建立他们自己的私人封地的危险吗？是的，这是极度不负责任的，原因我们在上一集的结尾已经谈到过，但为了回顾一下，诺曼底的继承权是动荡的。罗伯特确实有一个儿子，这个男孩七岁，名叫威廉，事实上，在他去朝圣之前，他已经正式指定这个男孩为他的继承人，并且他赢得了法兰克国王对此事的批准。
But this boy, to reiterate, is seven years old. And as we discussed in the previous episode, he is also illegitimate. I mean, that's not a killer blow, but it doesn't help. And so should anything happen to Robert on his pilgrimage, then the potential for disaster is absolutely enormous, as it would have been at any point in the dukedom's history. But particularly now you have this military revolution with the potential, as you've been saying, for kind of breakdown and anarchy. But you know, things seem to be going well. Robert has dazzled Constantinople and very satisfyingly, Falknera
但重申一下，这个男孩才七岁。正如我们在上一集讨论的那样，他也是个私生子。我的意思是，这不是致命一击，但也没有帮助。因此，如果罗伯特在朝圣途中发生任何事情，那么灾难的潜力绝对是巨大的，正如在公国历史上的任何时候一样。但尤其是现在你有了这场军事革命，正如你一直在说的，有着崩溃和无政府状态的潜力。但你知道，事情似乎进展顺利。罗伯特让君士坦丁堡大开眼界，非常令人满意的是，黑富尔克
has been on pilgrimage as well. Falknera is a great one for going on pilgrimage to Jerusalem. I think he does it five times. Anyway, he's there and Robert massively puts him in the shade. So that's great for Robert. He goes to Jerusalem again, cuts a tremendous dash, sets off back home. By late June 1035, he is approaching Constantinople. But then before he can cross the Bosphorus, disaster. Oh no, he falls sick. He is taken to the city of Nicaea on the south of the Straits. And there at the beginning of July, the Magnificent Duke of Normandy dies
也去朝圣了。黑富尔克很喜欢去耶路撒冷朝圣。我想他去了五次。无论如何，他在那里，而罗伯特极大地抢了他的风头。这对罗伯特来说太棒了。他再次去耶路撒冷，大出风头，然后动身回国。到1035年6月下旬，他正在接近君士坦丁堡。但就在他穿过博斯普鲁斯海峡之前，灾难降临了。哦不，他病倒了。他被带到海峡南部的尼西亚城。在那里，在七月初，伟大的诺曼底公爵去世了。
We mentioned how Fulton error is on pilgrimage. Yeah, and has been put in the shade by this guy who's his great rival. I mean There are rumors and reports that perhaps it's poison. It's literally it's literally as if you've been on holiday with Dan Snow and I would never poison dad No, he'd poison you no Dan would never you would put him in the shade Tom with your enormous download figures Come on, and my pistachios. Yeah, exactly and my gold shot mules Exactly. I think a wonderful way to end this this this half would be for me to read from Millennium my book on this very subject I mean, I can't read, I'm not reading that. You can read it.
我们提到过黑富尔克是如何去朝圣的。是的，而且被这个作为他最大竞争对手的家伙抢了风头。我的意思是，有传言和报道说也许是中毒了。这简直是，这简直就像你和丹·斯诺去度假一样，而我绝不会毒死爸爸。不，他会毒死你。不，丹绝不会。你会用你巨大的下载量抢走汤姆的风头，来吧，还有我的开心果。是的，正好还有我的镀金骡子。是的。我认为结束这半场的绝佳方式是由我来朗读《千年：关于这个主题的书》（Millennium）。我的意思是，我不会读那个。你可以读它。
Absolutely, you can read it. The Count of Anjou, whose princedom was separated from Normandy only by a single makeshift buffer, the unfortunate County of Maine, had long been angling to roll back Norman power. Now with Robert dead, such a goal appeared eminently achievable. William the New Duke was only eight years old. Normandy had effectively been decapitated. What an unbelievably thrilling cliffhanger. Join us after the break to find out what happens to William of Normandy. I'm David Ollishogga, historian and broadcaster. And I'm Sarah Churchwellhoge, historian and broadcaster.
绝对的，你可以读。安茹伯爵的领地与诺曼底仅隔着一个权宜之计的缓冲地带——不幸的曼恩伯爵领地，他长期以来一直企图扭转诺曼人的势力。现在随着罗伯特之死，这样一个目标似乎完全可以实现。新公爵威廉只有八岁。诺曼底实际上已经被斩首了。这是一个令人难以置信的悬念。休息一下后加入我们，看看诺曼底的威廉会发生什么。我是历史学家兼广播员大卫·奥利舒加。我是历史学家兼广播员莎拉·丘奇韦尔。
And I'm Sarah Churchwell, author, journalist and academic. And together, we are hosts of Goalhanger's latest podcast, Journey Through Time. We're going to be looking at hidden social histories behind famous chapters from the past. Asking what it was like to have lived through prohibition or to have been there on the ground during the great fire of London. We'll be uncovering all of that. And we'll have characters and stories that have been totally forgotten, but shouldn't have been.
我是作家、记者兼学者莎拉·丘奇韦尔。我们共同主持高挂公司的最新播客《时空之旅》。我们将探讨过去著名章节背后的隐藏社会历史。询问经历禁酒令是什么感觉，或者在伦敦大火期间亲历现场是什么感觉。我们将揭开这一切的面纱。我们还将拥有那些被彻底遗忘、但不该被遗忘的人物和故事。
This week, we're looking at a terror attack that shocked New York, that cost American lives, caused millions of dollars of damage to buildings across Manhattan, that led to the establishment of new security agencies, and that helped push the United States towards war. But it's not 9-11. This is the Black Tom explosion of 1916, the story of a massive sabotage campaign as Germany made a desperate effort
本周，我们将探讨一起震惊纽约的恐怖袭击，它夺去了美国人的生命，对曼哈顿各地的建筑物造成了数百万美元的破坏，导致了新安全机构的建立，并帮助推动美国走向战争。但这不是9·11。这是1916年的黑汤姆大爆炸，这是一个大规模破坏活动的故事，当时德国做出了绝望的努力
to keep America from helping the Allies during the First World War. And the cast of characters for this story involves playboy diplomats, there's a stranded sailor, an opera singer who's managing a brothel in New York, and there's a hapless spy who leaves secret documents on a train. So join us on Journey Through Time and hear a clip from the Black Tom story at the end of this episode.
以阻止美国在第一次世界大战期间帮助盟友。这个故事的角色阵容包括花花公子外交官、一名滞留的水手、一名在纽约经营妓院的女高音歌唱家，还有一个把秘密文件落在火车上的倒霉间谍。因此，请加入我们的《时空之旅》，并在本集结束时聆听黑汤姆故事的一个片段。
Welcome back to The Rest Is History. And so at last we come to one of the great monsters in all history, Duke William of Normandy, the man who shamed himself and his country by winning the Battle of Hastings and carrying out the Norman conquest. So we're in July 1035 and this blood-stained figure is at this point only eight years old. He's William the Bastard. Everyone calls him William the Bastard because he's not legitimate. And basically the odds are massively against it. I mean, he probably won't live to the end of the year. You see, I'm surprised you don't admire William.
欢迎回到《The Rest Is History》。因此，我们终于迎来了历史上的一大恶魔——诺曼底公爵威廉，这个通过赢得黑斯廷斯战役和进行诺曼征服而让自己和国家蒙羞的人。所以我们正处于1035年7月，这个血迹斑斑的人物此时只有八岁。他是威廉恶棍。每个人都叫他威廉恶棍，因为他不是嫡出的。基本上，形势对他是极其不利的。我的意思是，他可能活不到年底。你看，我很惊讶你居然不钦佩威廉。
Really? Because I like a ruthless... Yeah. I mean, ultimately a kindly man. I think there is something of Cromwell about William the Conqueror. Do you? Yeah. Kind of, he's a man of austere piety and given to brutal invasions of his neighbours. I think we said recently that I, and this series, there's nothing I like more than law and order. And he's very much a law and order man. Well, as we will see, because the news comes back to Normandy that he is now the Duke and he is really staring down the barrel. So as we said, he is called by his enemies, particularly Anjou, William the Bastard, and
真的吗？因为我喜欢无情的人……是的。归根结底是一个善良的人。我认为征服者威廉身上有克伦威尔的影子。是吗？是的。某种程度上，他是一个具有苦行虔诚并热衷于对邻居进行残酷入侵的人。我想我们最近说过，我以及这个系列，我最喜欢的就是法律和秩序。他非常注重法律和秩序。好吧，正如我们将看到的，因为消息传回诺曼底，他现在是公爵，他真的面临着严峻的考验。正如我们所说，他被他的敌人，特别是安茹人称为威廉恶棍，并且
I guess you could say he's a bastard in every sense of the word. Very good. So it is said that his mother was the daughter of a man who had prepared the dead for burial or an alternative story is that he was a tanner or perhaps he was both. But either way, you know, he is working with the dead. So he is seen as being a man polluted by rottenness and filth. And this is a very damaging charge because it implies that William, although of noble descent on his father's side, on his mother's side is shot through with baseness. And the thinking is that Robert, by taking to bed the daughter of a corpse handler has,
我想可以说他是名副其实的恶棍。非常好。据说他的母亲是一个为死者准备葬礼的人的女儿，另一个说法是他是一个制革匠，或者可能两者兼而有之。但无论哪种方式，你知道的，他都在和死者打交道。因此，他被视为一个被腐烂和污秽污染的人。这是一个非常具有破坏性的指控，因为它暗示威廉虽然父亲方面有高贵的血统，但在母亲方面却充满了卑微。人们的想法是，罗伯特把一个尸体处理员的女儿娶上床
as you would say, Dominic, bred a monster. Right. Yeah. And that this young Duke, if he is allowed to grow to adulthood, he will be fated to serve as the shroud winder, not of the dead, but of entire kingdoms. I mean, the people who say that are not wrong. Well, maybe. But to be honest, the Normans themselves don't really care about William's parentage, partly because actually his grandfather wasn't an undertaker or a Tanner. He was actually an official in the ducal court. So this was all kind of malevolent anti-Norman propaganda.
正如你所说，多米尼克，这是一个怪胎。没错。是的，这位年轻的公爵，如果他能活到成年，他注定将成为收尸人，但不是为死者，而是为整个王国。我的意思是，那些这么说的人并没有错。好吧，也许吧。但说实话，诺曼人自己其实并不在乎威廉的身世，部分原因其实是他的祖父并不是一个殡葬员或制革匠。他实际上是公爵宫廷的一名官员。所以这一切基本上都是恶意的反诺曼宣传。
And also it's because I think that they remain sufficiently Viking that they're not too worried about the issue of wives and concubines and things like that. They like the Rolling Stones. They don't care about petty morals. Well it is observed by the monk Rudolf Graeber who is a brilliant source for this whole period. It has always been their custom for as long as they've been settled in France to take us their princes, the offspring of concubines. So I guess you could kind of maybe say that the Rolling Stones, I don't
而且这也是因为我认为他们仍然保留着足够的维京习俗，所以他们不太担心妻子和妃嫔之类的问题。他们就像滚石乐队。他们不在乎那些琐碎的道德。正如僧侣鲁道夫·格拉伯所观察到的那样，他是整个时期绝佳的史料来源。自他们在法国定居以来，以妃嫔的后代作为他们的王子一直是他们长久以来的习俗。所以我想你大概可以说滚石乐队，我不知道。
know. Yeah, I think you probably could. And people may remember that there was this kind of similar issue with Canute wasn't there and he had two wives or was one a concubine or anything. Although it is interesting that times are definitely changing. So views on marriage are also part of this great revolutionary process that is kind of picking up speed at this time. And the Normans are really actually kind of starting to buy into this. The fact that William's father had gone on pilgrimage is kind of evidence of that. You know, they are very, very pious Christians and increasingly anxious not to seem on the wrong sides of this kind of great moral revolution. And this combines with a sense that the best way for a
不知道。是的，我想你大概可以这么说。人们可能还记得，克努特身上也有类似的问题，不是吗？他有两个妻子，还是其中一个是妃嫔什么的。尽管有趣的是，时代确实在改变。因此，对婚姻的看法也是这场正蓄势待发的伟大革命进程的一部分。诺曼人实际上也开始接受这一点了。威廉的父亲曾去朝圣就是一个证明。你知道的，他们是非常非常虔诚的基督徒，并且越来越焦虑，生怕自己站在这种伟大道德革命的错误一边。这也结合了一种观念，即贵族家族传承其祖产的最佳方式是不让继承权分散。所以你还记得当我们谈论法兰克人时，你曾对法兰克国王和皇帝不断在儿子之间分割祖产表示惊讶，并心想，他们怎么还没弄明白这是件坏事？同样，这也是他们开始意识到这一点的时期。所以皇室王朝，卡佩王朝已经明白了这一点。而且看起来刚刚去世的诺曼底公爵罗伯特也意识到了这一点。所以在生下威廉之后，他没有再娶妻子。而且很
noble family to pass on its patrimony is not to have a divided inheritance. So you remember when we talked about the Franks, you were expressing surprise that the Frankish kings and emperors kept dividing up their patrimony between their sons and thinking, well, why haven't they sussed out that this is a bad thing to do? This is again, is the period where they are starting to work that out. So the royal dynasty, the Capetian dynasty has worked this out. And it seems that Robert, the Duke of Normandy, who's just died, he had worked it out as well. So after he has fathered William, he doesn't take a wife. And it's
可能他这样做的原因是不希望继承权分散。他不想让任何人对威廉的存在产生怀疑。好吧，确实没有人怀疑，尽管威廉当时只有八岁。因此不可避免地，他那场并非本意的混乱统治的早期岁月将充满血腥和争夺。我的意思是，无论他做什么，你知道的，有多少八岁的孩子准备好掌控这个战士国家？当然。但我想如果有，你知道，另外两个兄弟，也许来自合法的渠道，
probable the reason he does this is he doesn't want to have a divided inheritance. He doesn't want anyone to doubt that William is there. Well, no one does doubt, although William is only eight years old. So inevitably, the early years of his inadvertent commerce reign are going to be very bloody and contested. I mean, whatever he does and you know, how many eight year olds are prepared to take the reins of this warrior state? Sure. But I think if there'd been, you know, two other brothers, maybe from a legitimate source,
那将是一个巨大的不稳定根源。但你说得对。我的意思是，他的处境糟透了。一位当代编年史家指出，许多诺曼人忘恩负义，开始堆积土堆，然后在上面为自己建造坚固的堡垒，这正是他们对忠诚淡漠的标志。基本上，这些就是被用作无政府状态工具的城堡。土丘城堡和带有护城河的防御工事，以及建在它们上面的塔楼。实质上，公国内部的敌对军阀
and that would have been a real source of instability. But you're right. I mean, he's in a terrible position. And a contemporary chronicler notes as a sign how, forgetful of their loyalties, many Normans set about piling up mounds of earth and then constructing fortified strongholds on them for themselves. So these are the castles being used as tools of anarchy, basically. The moths, the mounds of earth and the Baileys, the towers that are put on top of them. And essentially rival warlords within a dukedom
建造城堡是一个可怕的信号。这是国家崩溃的标志。这些军阀拥有城堡意味着他们可以对对手发动突袭。所以在威廉统治公国早期的几年里，绑架敌人的狂热蔚然成风。有一个臭名昭著的案例：一个人在自己的婚礼宴会上被绑架，带走、弄瞎、阉割。你知道，这可不是婚礼的好的开始。所以人们简直是在对反对派进行去势。无政府状态正在诺曼底蔓延，这是一个绝对糟糕的时期，并将永远被铭记为诺曼底经历过的最糟糕的时期。绝对糟糕的时期，并将永远被铭记为诺曼底经历过的最糟糕的时期。
building castles is a terrible sign. It's a sign of state breakdown. And the fact that these warlords have their castles means that they can launch raiding parties on their rivals. So you get this craze throughout the early years of William's dukedom for abducting foes. So there's a notorious case where one is abducted from his own wedding feast, carried off, blinded, castrated. You know, that's not a good start to a wedding. So people are literally neutering the opposition. And anarchy is spreading across Normandy and it's absolutely terrible time and will always be remembered as the worst time that Normandy ever endured. absolutely terrible time and will always be remembered as the worst time that Normandy ever endured.
那威廉呢？我的意思是，他才八岁。他在这一切当中在做什么？他大概不会到处去阉割别人吧。没有，而且他并非孤立无援。所以他确实有，你知道的，他得到了他家族中权势人物的支持，诺曼底的教会阶层对保持忠诚，并且他得到了法国国王的支持。
And what about William? I mean, he's only eight. What's he doing on all this? He's presumably not going around castrating people. No, and he's not without support. So he does have, you know, he has the backing of the powerful men in his own family, the church hierarchy in Normandy, they stay loyal to him and he has the support of the King of France.
这同样意义重大，但这并不足以阻止他的童年不断被暴力阴影笼罩。他的两名监护人相继被砍倒，他自己的家庭教师被谋杀，还有一个特别臭名昭著的事件：他在一个房间里，他的管家也在房间里睡觉。人们闯进来割断了管家的喉咙，鲜血喷涌而出。年轻的公爵正在睡觉，他醒来发现，天哪，他以为自己可能尿床了什么的。
And that again is not insignificant, but it's not enough to prevent his childhood from being constantly shadowed by violence. So two of his guardians are hacked down in quick succession, his own tutor is murdered and there's one particularly notorious occasion where he's in a room and his steward is also in the room asleep. People barge in and they cut the throat of the steward and the blood spills out. The young Duke is asleep and he wakes up and finds, oh my God, he thinks he's wet himself perhaps or something.
哦，不，这就像《教父》里的马头一样。是的，我的意思是，太可怕了。但当然，那个故事的重点是他们杀死了管家，但他们放过了威廉。人们并不是冲着威廉本人来的。他们利用了他无法控制这种无政府状态的处境，但他们并没有以消灭他为目标。对。我想你可以说，经历这些恐怖的过程，我的意思是，这磨练了他，不是吗？是的，很好。这是一个很好的说法。但是是的，我们应该用我们自己王室的眼光更仔细地思考一下这一点。可能有一种类似的、斯巴达式的教育。我以为以你对公立学校的热情，
Oh no, it's like the horse's head and the Godfather. Yeah, I mean so so, so terrible. But of course, the point of that story is they killed the steward, but they've left William alone. People are not after William himself. They're exploiting the fact that he is not in a position to reign in this anarchy, but they're not targeting him for elimination. Right. And I suppose you could say that the process of living through these horrors, I I mean, it's it's stealing him, isn't it? Yeah, it's good. It's a good bit. But yeah, we should think about this a little bit more carefully with our own royal family. There may be a similar, a similar Spartan education. I thought with your enthusiasm
你可能会说这可能是培育坚韧新精英的一种方式。没错。把他们送走去杀人。这就是菲利普亲王对国王做的事，戈登斯托恩学校。但实际上，我说的是斯巴达式，我的意思正如你在笔记中所说，诺曼人的教育确实有其斯巴达式的一面。所以像威廉这样的人，他从出生起就真正接受了战争、残酷和暴力的训练。我的意思是，这些是一个诺曼人、一个诺曼男人的职责。是的，女性也是如此。因此，贵族女孩们正是在这种环境中抚养长大的，
for public schools that you might say that this could be a way to breed a hardy new elite. Exactly. Send them off and murder people. This is what Prince Philip did with the King, Senator Gordonston. But there is actually, I said Spartan, but I mean you said it in your notes, there is something Spartan about a Norman's education. So somebody like William, he is being trained from, really from birth, for war, for cruelty, for violence. I mean that is, these are the duties of a Norman, of a Norman man. Yes, and indeed women. So aristocratic girls are being raised in this environment where,
你知道的，到处都是汗水、钢铁、马匹和训鹰术。实际上，就像一所英国女子公立学校。相当，是的，差不多。马匹和训鹰术。所以就像一所英国女子公立学校，实际上。相当。是的，差不多。马匹和残酷。因此，武器、马匹以及狩猎和训鹰术的练习，这些就是诺曼人的乐趣。是的。当然，这些也就是将在英国夺取权力的上层阶级的模式。是的。并且在很大程度上，直到今天仍然拥有大部分土地。
you know, it's all sweat and iron and horses and hawking. So like a British public school for girls, actually. Pretty, yeah, pretty much. Horses and Hawking. So like a British public school for girls, actually. Pretty. Yeah, pretty much. Horses cruelty. So arms and horses and the exercises of hunting and Hawking, such are the delights of a Norman. Yeah. And these are, of course, the patterns of the upper classes that will seize power in Britain. Yeah. And to a large extent, still own most of the land to this day.
所以，是的，这一切就是从这里开始的。而威廉本人，又像一个斯巴达人一样，是在狼群中抚养长大的。所以他被亲属、高贵的同伴所包围，这些被称为“内里”（Nuri），也就是那些在公爵身旁抚养长大的年轻男孩、年轻男子。因此，他们在成长过程中将自己视为威廉的战友。你知道的，这是一群接受过掠夺训练的食肉动物。他们在学什么？
So, yes, this is where it all begins. And William himself, again, like a Spartan, is raised as part of a wolf pack. So he's surrounded by kinsmen, by highborn friends, and these are called Nuri, so people who are young boys, young men who are nourished at the side of the Duke. And so they grow up thinking of themselves as Williams' brothers in arms. And you know, this is a pack of carnivores being trained to despoil. And what are they learning?
他们正在学习这种新型战争非常、非常苛刻的技能。所以你必须学会如何正确地操控长矛，如何在马鞍上坐稳并使用长矛。我的意思是，这是一项新技能和新要求，需要大量的训练，你知道的，需要数年的时间才能完美掌握，但威廉和他的“内里”、他的战友们，你知道的，这就是他们正在学习的。当然，他们还接受了所有尖端军事技术的训练，其中城堡建造最为明显。这一切都关乎进攻、掠夺和征服。所以这让我想起了亚历山大大帝和他的同伴们，他们带着他们著名的长马其顿长矛长大，
They are learning the skills that are very, very demanding for this new way of war. So you have to learn how to handle a lance properly, to sit in a saddle and use a lance. I mean, this is a new skill and new requirement, takes a lot of training and, you know, it takes years to perfect, but William and his Nuri, his comrades, you know, this is what they're learning. And of course, they're also trained in all the cutting edge military technology of which castle building is the most obvious. And it's all about attack, about spoliation, about conquest. So I mean, that reminds me a little bit of Alexander the Great and his companions being
还有征服的艺术以及诸如此类的事情。然而，这其中还有一个不同的维度，因为正如你在笔记中所指出的那样，威廉的成长过程中也被灌输了极度的虔诚，甚至可以说是对信仰狂热般的执着，以及他坚信自己是某种新型基督教信仰的化身，我想。我认为这与克伦威尔又有某种轻微的相似之处。好吧。他能够犯下看似暴行的罪行，但却带着绝对的信念，即他在履行上帝的意志。这种信仰带有一种新型的军事化倾向，
raised with their famously long Macedonian spears, and you know, the arts of conquest and all of that kind of thing. However, there was a different dimension to this, because as you point out in your notes, William is also being raised to be extremely pious, not to say almost fanatical in his attachment to the faith and his belief that he is the embodiment of a kind of new kind of Christian faith, I guess. That again, I think there's a kind of slight parallel there with Cromwell. Okay. He's able to commit what seem to be atrocities, but do so in the absolute conviction that he is fulfilling God's will. And there is a kind of new type of militancy to this faith
其原因我们可能会在本系列的后面探讨。但威廉绝对是在这种情感的热情和精神烈焰中长大的。他认为自己作为战士的职责与赋予臣民和平的职责之间绝对没有任何矛盾，因为只有作为一个军阀，他才能将自己的权威强加给诺曼人。如果所有的诺曼人都是掠夺者，那么他必须确立自己作为顶级掠夺者、作为食物链顶端掠夺者的地位。甚至诺曼人自己也能认识到，如果威廉能够基本上击垮任何胆敢与他竞争的人，这可能对公国是最好的。因此，有一位英国编年史家在诺曼底的一个修道院里，在诺曼征服后写道，他谈论诺曼人的方式，我想就像你谈论狗一样。为了以正义和坚定来管束诺曼人，他们将证明自己是伟大的勇士，在艰巨的任务中无敌地向前冲锋，证明自己的力量，坚决战胜所有敌人。但没有这样的统治，他们会互相残杀、自取灭亡，因为他们渴望叛乱，珍视煽动，随时准备进行任何背叛。”我想威廉无疑是这样认为的。这坚定了他的决心，绝不容忍任何对手。他越大，就越准备好将这种权威强加给他饱受战争蹂躏的公国，显然是为了那些不想生活在无政府状态中、不想在婚礼上被绑架和阉割的人们的利益。现在让我们转向见证这一切的两个人。
for reasons that we may become to later in this series. But William absolutely is raised in the kind of the fervor in the spirit flame of this sense. And he sees absolutely no contradiction between his vocation as a warrior and his duty to give his subjects peace because it's only as a warlord that he can stamp his authority on the Normans. If all the Normans are predators, then he has to establish himself as the top predator, as the apex predator. And even the Normans themselves can recognize that it would probably be best for the dukedom if William is able to essentially slap down anyone who would think to rival him. So there's an English chronicle writing after the Norman conquest in an abbey in Normandy, who writes about the Normans, rather as you would about dogs, I think. For discipline the Normans with justice and firmness and they will prove
你看到这一切正在发生。他们不是诺曼底出生。他们是威廉宫廷的流亡者，这些人就是我们上周提到的，那些长期统治英国的盎格鲁-萨ク森血脉的……所谓的这个血脉的神话创立者，他们是埃德蒙·伊恩赛德的同父异母兄弟。他们叫阿尔弗雷德和爱德华。他们是“无准备者”埃塞尔雷德的儿子，他们自1016年以来就一直在诺曼底。所以在威廉甚至继承爵位之前，他们就在那里呆了二十年，在宫廷里闲逛。他们一直在干什么？他们一直在诺曼底闲逛，因为他们不想
themselves men of great valour who press invincibly to the fore in arduous undertakings and proving their strength fight resolutely to overcome all enemies. But without such rule, they tear each other to pieces and destroy themselves, for they hanker after rebellion, cherish sedition and are ready for any treachery." And I think William undoubtedly thinks this. And it steals him in his determination not to tolerate any rival. And the older he gets, the readier he is to kind of impose this authority on his war-torn dukedom for the benefit obviously of people who don't want to live in anarchy and be abducted on their wedding day and castrated. Now let's move to two people who are witnesses to all this.
让克努特谋杀他们。尽管他们的母亲埃玛现在已经嫁给克努特了，但她已经对他们不管不顾了。她不在乎他们。她基本上认为他们是失败者。她不需要为他们操心。我想这并不令人意外，埃玛，我的意思是，她是个累赘。她非常精明冷酷。
You see all this happening. They are not Norman Bourne. they are exiles at Williams Court and these are people that we mentioned last week who are the as to the anglo-saxon bloodline that have ruled England for so long. so-called mythical founder of this bloodline and these are the half brothers of Edmund Ironside They are called Alfred and Edward They are the sons of Ethelred the Unready and they have been in Normandy since 1016 So they were there for 20 years before William even succeeded hanging around at the court What's been going on with them? They've been hanging out in Normandy because they don't want
她非常善于算计。基本上，她感兴趣的是维护自己的权力。她看出爱德华或阿尔弗雷德没有任何希望继承已经被丹麦君主国夺取的王位。因此，她支持的儿子是她与克努特所生的儿子，一个叫哈绍克努特的人。那是她需要继承她丈夫的人。现在出现了一个复杂情况，因为她当然有一个死敌，那就是另一个妻子、妃嫔，无论你想怎么称呼她。是的。来自米德兰兹的阿尔夫吉夫，克努特的第一个妻子，克努特把她安置在丹麦，
Knute to murder them essentially. Um, despite the fact that their mother, Emma is now married to Knute, but she's kind of washed her hands of them. She doesn't care about them. She essentially sees them as, as losers. She doesn't need to worry about them. And I think this isn't really surprising, Emma, I mean, she is a baggage. She is very hard-nosed.
她同样为克努特生了一个儿子哈罗德，我们称他为“兔足哈罗德”，尽管这个绰号直到12世纪才出现。即便如此，埃玛对阿尔夫吉夫还是有一些优势的。她是克努特的正妻。她是英国王后。她曾为此接受过涂油加冕礼。正因为如此，英国大多数的权力操纵者，比如伯爵等等，都接受哈绍克努特是合法继承人，认为他才是理应继承克努特的人。
She's very calculating. And essentially, she's interested in upholding her power. And she can see that there's no prospect of Edward or Alfred succeeding to a throne that has now been seized by a Danish monarchy. And therefore the son that she is backing is her son by Canute, a guy called Halfa Canute. That is the person that she needs to succeed her husband. Now there is a complication because of course she has a deadly rival who is this other wife concubine, whatever you want to call her. Yeah. Alf Giffo from the Midlands, Canute's first wife, who Canute has set up in Denmark and
虽然，如果我可以此时插话，这其中难道没有一点地区性的维度吗？埃玛和哈绍克努特往往得到威塞克斯的大地主或大人物的支持，而你提到的阿尔夫吉夫来自米德兰兹，麦西亚人更有可能支持她和她的儿子兔足哈罗德。是的，但我仍然认为，如果克努特死后哈绍克努特在场，那么英国的大多数贤人会议成员和伯爵可能会接受哈绍克努特为国王。然而问题是，事情并不是这样的。距离伟大的罗伯特在尼西亚去世已经过去几个月了。
who likewise has given Canute a son, Harold, who we'll call Harold Harefoot, even though that nickname doesn't emerge until the 12th century. Even so, Emma has kind of advantages over Alf Giffo. She is Canute's principal wife. She's the Queen of England. She's been anointed as such. And because of this, most of the power breakers in England, so the Earls and so on, they accept that Harthacanute is the legitimate heir, that he is the guy who properly should succeed Canute.
那是1035年的秋天，克努特去世了，这个时机对埃玛来说绝对是一场灾难，因为如你所说，哈绍克努特在丹麦，而兔足哈罗德在英国。所以他是现场的人。更糟糕的是，埃玛给哈桑发了些急件说，你知道，来这里，来夺取王位，但他来不了，因为他必须处理挪威的一场叛乱。我的意思是，这挺有趣的，因为这几乎就像他在参加竞选。他必须宴请贤人会议的各个成员，试图说服他们他应该继位成为英国国王，而哈绍克努特应该被抛弃。埃玛同样在拼命竞选，希望哈绍克努特能继位。所以她散布谣言说，
Although, if I can jump in at this point, is there not a slight regional dimension to this in that Emma and Harthacanute tend to have the support of the kind of the big landers or the big men in Wessex, but you mentioned Elf Gifu, she's from the Midlands and the Mercians are more likely to back her and her son Harold Harefoot. Yes, but I still think that had Harthacanute been on the scene when Canute dies, then probably most of the wit and most of the earls in England would have accepted half the canute as king. The problem is, however, it doesn't turn out like that. We're a few months on from the death of Robert the Magnificent in Nicaea.
哈罗德其实是个调包儿，是一个侍女的儿子，因此根本算不上合法，根本不是克努特的儿子。当这招不管用时，她把自己 barricaded 在温彻斯特，那是举行加冕典礼的地方，试图阻止哈罗德悄悄溜进去并在那里给自己加冕。但接着阿尔夫吉夫出现在现场。她从丹麦乘船而来。所以奇怪的是，她和她的对手、与哈绍克努特一起在丹麦。这一切都乱成一团，但阿尔夫吉夫非常积极主动，讨厌埃玛，希望她的儿子继位。
It's the autumn of 1035, Canute dies and the timing is an absolute disaster for Emma because as you say, half the Canute is in Denmark and Harold Harefoot is in England. So he is the guy on the scene. And what makes it even worse, Emma sends kind of frantic messages to Hassan saying, you know, come here, come and get the throne, but he can't because he's having to deal with a revolt in Norway. I mean, it's kind of interesting because it's almost like he's running an election. He has to wine and dine all the various members of the Witan to try and persuade them that he should succeed as King of England and that Harthacnut should be binned. And Emma is likewise frantically campaigning for Arthur Canute to succeed. So she spreads rumors that
所以她确实乘船赶来，而且她非常擅长竞选。她宴请了各个伯爵、雅尔以及贤人会议的成员，敦促他们选择哈罗德为国王。正如你所说，英国有人，特别是麦西亚，本能地想要支持阿尔夫吉夫，她的亲戚也在其中。她在麦西亚很有背景。基本上所有的势头都在哈罗德一边。于是他向埃玛把自己 barricaded 起来的温彻斯特进军。埃玛意识到一切对她来说都结束了。她逃跑了，离开了
Harold was actually a changing, that he was the son of a servant woman, therefore not remotely legitimate, not the son of Canute at all. And when this doesn't work, she barricades herself in Winchester, which is the place where the coronation would happen to try and stop Harold from kind of sneaking in and having himself crowned there. But then Elf Gifu turns up on the scene. She sailed from Denmark. So bizarrely, she's in Denmark with her rival, with Harthacanth. It's all mixed up, but Elf Gifu is very proactive, hates Emma, wants her boy to succeed.
温彻斯特，哈罗德夺取了盎格鲁-萨克森编年史所描述的“国王克努特所有的最佳财宝”，基本上就是加冕典礼的王权信物。所以他现在拥有了加冕所需的东西。如果我们把故事停在这里，埃玛和哈绍克在这一边，看起来他们输了。而在另一边，阿尔夫吉夫和她的儿子兔足哈罗德，看起来这个叫兔足的家伙，尽管这不是他的名字，他要当国王了，而且一切对都很顺利。所以现在埃玛要被晾在一边了，她做了一件我当时认为绝对疯狂的事。她放弃了她的候选人、她的儿子，然后说，好吧，其实一开始并不是为了他。实际上这更多是关于我自己的。所以现在她把那两个来自诺曼底的失败者挖出来说，那这两个人怎么样，把他们也卷进来。我知道她是一个如此有趣地可怕且冷酷的角色。
So she does come sailing over and she's very good at campaigning. She wines and dines all the various earls and yarls and people, the members of the Witan, urging them to choose Harold as king. And because as you said, there are people in England, particularly in Mercia, who instinctively do want to back Elf Gifu's relatives being among them. She's very well connected in Mercia. And essentially the kind of the momentum is all with Harold. And so he marches on Winchester where Emma has barricaded herself. Emma realizes it's all up for her. She runs away, leaves
因为当然，这两个小伙子来英国是极其冒险的，他们已经20年没去过英国了，但他们也有20年没见过她了。我的意思是他们和她没有任何关系，但她却说，好吧，你知道，你们两个现在，
Winchester, and Harold seizes what the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle describes as all King Canute's best valuables, essentially the coronation regalia. So he's got what he needs now to be crowned. If we stop the story there, Emma and Harthak are on one side and they look like they've lost. And on the other side, Elf Gifu and her son, Harold Harefoot, looks like this bloke Harefoot, even though it's not his name, he's going to be king and he's got it all going on for him. So now Emma's going to be out in the cold and she does something that I think is absolutely bonkers at this point. She drops her candidate, her son and says, well, it wasn't really
实际上我要开始给你们寄圣诞贺卡了。这绝对是，绝对是疯狂的，但他们确实应母亲的要求来了。我想他们心里可能会想，好吧，也许这里有个让我们回的机会。所以第一个到达的是长子爱德华，他在南安普顿登陆。但我的意思是，欢迎委员会并没有想象的那么好。他看了一眼，心想，天哪，我得离开这里。然后他乘船回了诺曼底。是的。
about him in the first place. Actually it's more about me. So now she digs out the two losers from Normandy and says, what about the, it throws them into the mix. I know she's such a entertainingly horrible and ruthless character Because of course, it's incredibly risky for these two lads to come over to to England I haven't been to in England for 20 years, but they haven't seen her for 20 years either I mean they have no relationship with her whatsoever, but she's like right, you know you two now
在那之后不久，阿尔弗雷德自己渡海而来，一登陆就被抓了，他和他的随从受到了非常非常残酷的对待。我们被告知，他的随从被卖为奴隶、残酷谋杀、戴上枷锁、弄瞎、残害并剥头皮。阿尔弗雷德本人被带到东盎格利亚中部的伊利，大致在一个被沼泽环绕的岛上。在那里，他被刺瞎双眼，不久后因伤势过重而死。而妈妈根本不在乎。好吧，妈妈其实在乎，因为现在你知道了，那次尝试失败了。所以她逃到了法兰德斯。
I'm actually I'm gonna start sending you Christmas cards. It's absolutely, it's absolutely mad, but they do come in answer to their mother's request. I guess they kind of feel, well, maybe there's an opening here for us to come back. So the first to arrive is the eldest, Edward, and he lands at Southampton. But I mean, the welcoming committee is not all it might be. He has a look at it and he thinks, Oh God, I'm out of here. And he sails back to Normandy. Yeah.
当然，每个人都在说她表现得太糟糕了。我的意思是，这是极其怪异的行为。所以她又开始疯狂地编造谎言，说，其实并不是我给爱德华和阿尔弗雷德写的信。是兔足哈罗德干的。这完全没有道理。那纯粹是个谎言。不，因为上面有她的印章。
And then shortly after that, Alfred makes his own crossing and he lands immediately, gets captured and him and all his followers are treated very, very brutally. So we're told that his followers are stalled into slavery, cruelly murdered, laid down with chains, blinded, mutilated and scalped. And Alfred himself is taken to Ely in the middle of East Anglia, kind of on an island surrounded by the Fens. And there he is blinded and he dies soon afterwards of his wounds. And mummy doesn't care. Well, mummy does care because now you know, that attempts failed. So she runs away to Flanders.
而她说，哦，他伪造了我的印章。他黑了我的账户。没错。这太可怕了。是的。到了1038年，当埃玛召唤爱德华去法兰德斯与她会合时，他说，门都没有。我受够了。好吧，换作你也会这么做。
And of course, everyone is saying she's behaved terribly. I mean, monstrous behavior. And so she starts kind of again spinning frantically and saying, actually, it wasn't me who sent, you know, the letters to Edward and Alfred. It was Harold Harefoot who did it. There's no truth in that. That's just a lie. No, because it was her seal on it.
我的意思是，那可不是你想与之团聚的母亲，坦率地说。但问题是，这绝对是个疯狂的故事到目前为止。所有这些叫兔足和哈绍克努特之类的人，还有荒谬的转折。但现在这个故事又有一个疯狂的转折，你知道的，如果你是《权力的游戏》的编剧，你会说，拜托，这有点过分了。所以兔足哈罗德基本赢了。他是国王了。
And she's saying, oh, he faked my seal. He hacked my account. Right. That's terrible. Yeah. And in 1038, when Emma summons Edward to go and join her in Flanders, he says, no way. I've had enough. Well, you wouldn't.
岁月流逝。他25岁。他还可以再活40年。这个播客的很多英国听众可能会想，我其实从来没听说过这个叫兔足哈罗德的家伙。我认为有理由说他是统治过英国的最默默无闻的国王。人们对他一无所知。我从没听说过他。我对一无所知。我不相信这个人曾经是英国国王。原因在于史料太零碎、太模糊，而且
I mean, that's not a mother you want to be reunited with, frankly. But here's the thing, right? So this has been a mad story so far. All these people called Harefoot and Arthur Canute and whatnot, and just ridiculous twists. But now there was another insane twist to this story, which, you know, if you were the Game of Thrones script writer, you'd say, come on, this is a bit much. So Harold Harefoot basically has won. He's king.
令人难以置信的转折。他莫名其妙地突然猝死，没有任何好理由。故事中又一个莫名其妙突然猝死的人物。是的。所以他走了。这对于哈绍克努特和埃玛来说显然是个天大的好消息。所以在兔足哈罗德死后三个月，哈绍克努特在肯特登陆，谁会和他在一起呢，正是他那个极度自我满足、欣喜若狂的母亲。好吧。所以哈绍克努特为了去英国
The years go by. He is 25 years old. He could live for another 40 years. A lot of English listeners to this podcast may be thinking, I've actually never heard of this bloke, Harold Harefoot. I think there's a case for saying he's the most obscure king who's ever ruled England. People know nothing about him. I've never heard of him. I know nothing about him. I don't believe this man was ever King of England. And the reason for that is the sources are so kind of fragmentary and vague, but also
不得不与挪威国王达成相当苛刻的条件。所以，他永远放弃了对挪威的要求。有一个传说，我的意思是，如果这是真的，对未来的发展可能意义重大，那就是他与挪威国王、一个叫马格纳斯的家伙达成协议，无论他们俩谁先死，如果他们死时没有继承人，那么另一个人将继承王国。这只是埋下一颗种子。
unbelievable twist. He drops dead out of nowhere for no good reason. Yet another character in this story who drops dead out of from nowhere. Yeah. So he's gone. And this is obviously brilliant news for a half Canute and for Emma. So three months after the death of Harold Hereford, half the canute lands in Kent and who should be with him, but his very, very self satisfied mother, who's absolutely delighted. Right. So half the canute to get to England
如果以后有另一个挪威国王在附近游荡，并且出现英国继承危机，他可能会把这个挖出来说，哇，我其实有权继承。是的，我加入了。我现在是英国国王了。那么，哈绍克努特干得怎么样？他太糟糕了。所以……我加入了。我现在是英国国王了。所以，嗯，那么哈绍克努特干得怎么样？他太糟糕了。所以我想他的统治听起来很棒。这很像利兹·特拉斯的风格，不是吗？是的。
has had to agree quite stiff terms with the King of Norway. So, he abandons his claim to Norway for good. And there is a story, which is, I mean, if it's true, is potentially very significant for future developments, that he had agreed with the Norwegian King, a guy called Magnus, that whichever of the two die first, if they die without an heir, then the other one will inherit the kingdom. That's just so that seed.
所以温彻斯特坐着一个特拉斯……哈绍克努特做的第一件事就是表现得很大方，他把同母异父的兄弟兔足哈罗德的尸体挖出来，拖过一个下水道，然后扔进泰晤士河里，弄得全是粪便。然后他强征巨额税收，导致经济崩溃。这只是一个小特拉斯。这更像是瑞秋·里夫斯的风格。那是瑞秋·里夫斯式的，但随后产生了特拉斯效应。
If later on there's another King of Norway hanging around and there's an English succession crisis, he might dig this out and say, whoa, I'm actually entitled. Yeah, I'm in. I'm the King of England now. So, how does Hathkenut do? He's terrible. So... I'm in. I'm the king of England now. So, um, so how does half can eat do he's terrible. So I think his reign sounds brilliant. It's very list trust like, isn't it? Yeah.
所以盎格鲁-萨克森编年史，我在这里略微意译一下，写道：“所有曾经热情欢迎他掌权的人现在都决定他是个废物。”这可能是因为他正在失去支持，这可能是因为他此时已经生病了，这可能是因为埃玛仍在运筹帷幄，他邀请他的同母异父兄弟爱德华从诺曼底过来加入他，而爱德华这次真的来了——我的意思是，也许他确实病了，因为在1042年6月，也就是说他只统治了短短几年，他在一场婚礼宴会上饮酒。我读到是在兰贝斯。
So there's this lettuce sitting in, sitting in Winchester. So the first thing half canoe does is he shows himself a good sport by digging up the corpse of his half-brother Harold Harefoot, dragging it through a sewer and then dumping it all shit-stained in the Thames. He then imposes massive tax rises and crashes the economy. That's only a demi-truss. That's more of a kind of Rachel Reeves. That's a Rachel Reeves, but then a truss effect.
在兰贝斯，是的。当突然间，正如盎格鲁-萨克森编年史所描述的那样，他伴随着可怕的痉挛倒在地上，周围的人抓住他，此后他一句话也没说，就离世了。这就是为什么你永远无法真正把这拍成一部剧，因为人们会说，我在这两个角色上投入了太多感情，兔足和哈绍克努特之间的这场宿怨，我以为会主导整个剧集。而我知道他们俩都莫名其妙地退场了。但与此同时在挪威，挪威国王马格纳斯，一个类似幕后的人物，但正如你一直所说，这是他的机会。
So the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle, and I'm slightly paraphrasing here, writes, all who had enthusiastically welcomed his coming to power now decided he was useless. And it may be because he's losing support, it may be because he's already ill by this point, it may be because Emma is still on manoeuvres, that he invites his half-brother Edward over from Normandy to join him and Edward this time does come, I mean maybe he is ill because in June 1042, so he has ruled only for a couple of years, he's drinking at a wedding feast. In Lambeth I read.
好吧，这是他的机会。这是他宣称王位机会，但英国人不想要他，这意味着唯一貌似合理的可能候选人是埃玛的另一个儿子爱德华，埃塞尔雷德的儿子，他是阿尔弗雷德大帝和最终的塞尔迪克的后代。所以难以置信的是，塞尔迪克王朝复辟了。“无准备者”埃塞尔雷德的血脉笑到了最后。绝对的。所以1043年复活节，爱德华被加冕为国王，人们可能会纳闷，你知道，埃玛对此一定欣喜若狂。
In Lambeth, yes. When suddenly as the Anglo-Saxon Chronicleicle puts it he fell to the earth with an awful convulsion and Those who were close by took hold of him and he spoke no word afterwards, but passed away This is why you could never really make a drama of this because people would say I've invested so much in these two characters This feud between hair foot and half the canoe that I assume will dominate the rest of the series And I know they're both dropped out for no obvious reason. But meanwhile in Norway, King Magnus, kind of offstage character, but as you've been saying, this is his chance.
她胜利了。是的。一点也没有。爱德华对母亲的怨恨依然非常强烈。所以他没收了她所有的财宝，并将她驱逐出宫廷。难以置信的是，她随后开始与挪威国王马格纳斯密谋推翻自己的儿子。这简直是精神错乱的行为。但这并没有成功。所以她基本上就，她怎么了？她只是……
Well, this is his chance. This is chance to claim the throne, but the English don't want him and that means that the only plausible possible candidate is Emma's other son, Edward, the son of Athelred who is a descendant of Alfred the Great and ultimately Kurdic. And so unbelievably the Kurdic Ingas have been restored. The line of Athelred the Unready had the last laugh. Absolutely. So Easter 1043, Edward is crowned king and people may be wondering, you know, Emma must be exultant about this.
她只是在默默无闻中渐渐枯萎。所以她于1052年去世。她被埋葬在温彻斯特，与克努特、哈绍克努特合葬在一起，而爱德华现在是国王了。正当英国发生这一切的时候，威廉正在长大成人。1047年，他19岁。他迎战了一场大叛乱，第一次骑马出征并取得了非常血腥的胜利。在这场伟大胜利的返程中，他拆除了大量非法修建的城堡，以此来强力宣示他胜利的含义。随着他步入二十多岁，每个人都清楚诺曼底的无政府状态已经结束，强有力的统治已经恢复，威廉将成为一个受人尊敬和畏惧的公爵。
She's triumphant. Yeah. Not a bit of it. Edward's grudge against his mother is still going strong. So he confiscates all her treasure and banishes her from court. And unbelievably she then starts plotting with Magnus, the king of Norway, to overthrow her own son. And it's just absolutely deranged behaviour. But that doesn't work out. So she just basically then, what happens to her? She just gets...
是的。与此同时，威廉本人，你知道的，看着英国发生的一切，他一定在思考爱德华意外登上英国王位的教训，他一定反思道，这说明篡位者如果在上帝的庇佑下是可以被推翻的，那些受上帝庇佑的人可以宣称王位，一个人可以从诺曼底前往英国并成为国王。但这太不可能了，对吧？因为这个最终成为国王的家伙爱德华，他身体健康，他可能会有儿子，如果真的发生那种情况，你知道，将不会有
She just kind of withers away in obscurity. So she dies in 1052. She's buried in Winchester alongside Canute and half the Canute and Edward is now king. So while all this has been going on in England, William has been coming of age. And in 1047, he's 19 years old. He faces down a great rebellion and he rides out to battle for the first time and he secures a very bloody victory. And riding back from this great victory, he rams home the implications of his triumph by dismantling a large number of illegally raised castles. And as he enters his twenties, it is clear to everyone that the anarchy in Normandy is over, that strong rule has been re-established, that William is going to be a duke to respect and to fear.
任何机会。不会有空缺。不，不会有空缺。但也假设爱德华没有儿子，所以有了一个空缺。这以假设挪威或英国本土不会有人不认为自己也许应该成为国王。在英国本土。我不知道你当时在想谁，汤姆。好吧，我们将在下一期节目中揭晓答案，当我们转向英国历史上一位璀璨的明星，最后一位英国国王，所有认识他的人的英雄，哈罗德·戈德温森的故事。
Yeah. And meanwhile, William himself, you know, watching what's been going on in England, he must have been pondering the lessons of Edward's unexpected accession to the English throne and he must have reflected, well, this teaches that usurpers can be toppled if they have God's favour at their back, that those who are favoured by God can claim thrones and that a man can travel from Normandy to England and become a king. But that's all very unlikely, right? Because this guy Edward who's finally become king, he's hail and hearty, he could have sons and if that were to happen, you know, there would be
现在，如果你想立刻听到那一期节目，而且为什么不呢？如果你是“历史其余部分”俱乐部的会员，你就可以听到。如果你还不是会员，只需前往therestlesshistory.com注册即可。但我们下次会带着这个史诗传奇中下一个惊心动魄的章节回归。再见。再见。这里是我们之前提到的那个片段。渐渐地，在这个时期，你看到的是人们对所谓……的担忧日益加剧。
no opening whatsoever. There'd be no vacancy. No, there'd be no vacancy. But also just suppose that Edward doesn't have sons and so there is a vacancy. It presupposes that there wouldn't be people in Norway or indeed in England itself who might not have thoughts that perhaps they should become king. In England itself. I wonder who you could be thinking about there, Tom. Well, we will find out in our next episode when we turn to one of the glittering stars of English history, the last English king, hero to all who knew him, the story of Harold
混血美国人。这种观点认为外来移民社群有着分裂的效忠对象。因此，对效忠测试的呼声越来越高。威尔逊发表了一场非常著名的演讲，其中他使用了一个著名的短语，而这个短语你花了很长时间研究，萨拉。那就是询问这些对其他国家效忠的美国人，在关键时刻，是否会把美国放在首位。这就是那个短语，对吧？
Godwinson. Now, if you want to hear that episode right now, and why wouldn't you? You can if you're a member of the Rest is History Club. And if you're not already a member then just go to therestlesshistory.com and sign up. But we will be back next time with the next thrilling chapter in this epic saga. Bye bye. Bye bye. Here's that clip we mentioned earlier on. And gradually what you see in this period is mounting concern over what became called
美国优先。这个短语最早于1915年在这种背景下普及，即黑汤姆事件前的一年，当时威尔逊发表了一场演讲，针对人们对混血美国人日益增长的担忧，即他们是否是真正的美国人。威尔逊的表达方式是，他要求移民社群站出来，明确说明，他说，是美国优先，还是不是？就在那时，“美国优先”成了一个极其流行的短语。它基本上主导了接下来十年美国政治话语。然后它有点消退，接着在二战期间又卷土重来，当时它被用来讨论美国是否应该参战。然后它长期处于闲置状态，直到在21世纪戏剧性地重现，听众对此会很熟悉。如果你想听完整版节目，无论你在哪里收听播客，都可以收听“穿越时空的旅程”。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
hyphenate Americans. This idea that foreign immigrant communities had divided allegiances. And so there are increasing demands for effectively loyalty tests. And Wilson gives a very famous speech in which he uses a famous phrase, and that's a phrase that you have spent a long time studying, Sarah. And that is to ask whether these Americans who have loyalties to other nations will, when it comes down to it, whether they will put America first. And that's the phrase, right?
加了连字符的美国人。这种认为外国移民群体有着分裂效忠对象的观点。因此，社会上越来越强烈地要求进行实质上的忠诚测试。威尔逊发表了一场非常著名的演讲，其中他使用了一个著名的短语，这也是你花了很长时间研究的短语，萨拉。那就是质问这些对其他国家效忠的美国人，在关键时刻，是否会把美国放在第一位。这就是那个短语，对吧？
America first. It is a phrase that was first popularized in this context in 1915, a year before Black Tom, in a speech that Wilson gave addressing these mounting concerns about hyphenate Americans, about whether they were real Americans or not. And the way that Wilson put it was he said, he demanded that immigrant communities stand up and state explicitly whether, he said, is it America first or is it not? And at that point, America first became an incredibly popular phrase. It basically dominates American political discourse for the next decade. Then it kind of subsided and then it has a resurgence around World War II when it was used to talk about whether
美国第一。这个短语在1915年的这种语境下首次流行起来，也就是“黑汤姆”事件发生的前一年。当时威尔逊发表了一场演讲，回应了对加利福尼亚州等带有连字符的美国人（即移民）的种种日益增加的关切，质疑他们究竟是不是真正的美国人。威尔逊当时的表达方式是，他要求移民群体站出来，明确表态，他说：这究竟是不是美国第一？在那个时候，“美国第一”成了一个极其流行的短语。在接下来的十年里，它基本上主导了美国的政治话语。然后它渐渐沉寂下去，但在二战前后又再度复兴，当时被用来讨论
America should enter the Second World War. And then it went into abeyance for a long time until it made a dramatic reappearance in the 21st century, which listeners will be familiar with. If you want to hear the full episode, listen to Journey Through Time wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
美国是否应该加入第二次世界大战。随后它沉寂了很长一段时间，直到在21世纪戏剧性地重新出现，听众们对此应该会很熟悉。如果您想收听完整单集，请在您获取播客的任何平台上收听《穿越时空的旅程》。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。